ينضم الينا من الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره هيثم
ويت هيثم مرحبا بك معنا من جديد نحدث معك
اذا اماكن وما اسفرت عنه هذه الاشتباكات
في الخرطوم من الصباح
نعم محمد المشهد
الميداني ما يزال على ما هو عليه من حاله
الاشتباكات المستمره في وسط الخرطوم وخاصه
منطقه
المتاخمه للقياده العامه وفي الخرطوم بحري
وفي
وسط الخرطوم منطقه السوق العربي كانت
ساعات الماضيه شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه في تلك
المناطق حتى الان يعني ما نزل نسمع دوي
الانفجارات او ذوي الديانات التي تطلق من
الاسلحه الثقيله هذا المشهد ظل على ما هو
عليه منذ الصباح وحتى الان مع التوارث
البيانات المستمره من الجيش السوداني بانه
يعني احكم السيطره على معظم المقر
سواء كانت العسكريه والاستراتيجيه وان
بحسب ما اورده الجيش انه يمضي نحو نهايات
هذه
المعركه بعد ايضا الدخول سلاح الطيران الى
ساحه المعركه واستهدافه لمواقع يقول انها
تتبع لقوات الدعم السريع وهو السلاح الذي
ربما يكون حاسم في مثل هذه
المعارك وايضا سلاح المدرعات التي يمتلكها
الجيش كل هذه الاسلحه الثقيله ولكن من
الجانب الاخر ايضا الدعم السريع يعني
بياناته اقل
شحال من بيانات الجيش السوداني ولكن
يقولون بانهم ايضا مسيطرون على مواقع
عديده
في في المناطق الاستراتيجيه سواء كان في
وسط الخرطوم او في مناطق اخرى ايضا الانبا
تتحدث عن
بعض الاشتباكات في مناطق اخرى خارج نطاق
العاصمه السود كان كان هناك اشتباكات في
بورسودان اعلن الجيش سيطرته على مقر الدعم
السريع ايضا قبل قليل اورد الجيش في خبر
عجل بانه تم الاستيلاء على اكبر قاعده
عسكريه تتبع الدعم السريع في منطقه كرري
هذا ما اورده الجيش قبل قليل في في خبر
عاجل ولكن كل هذه البيانات وكل هذه
التصريحات التي تصدر يعني لا ندري على
الارض كيف تسير الامور ما نسمعه هو فقط
هذه هذا الدوين من الاسلحه الثقيله وهذه
الانفجارات المتتاليه من قبل القوات
المتحاربه على ساحه المعركه المؤكد ان
الساحه المعركه تشهد يعني حربا متواصله
واشتباكات متواصله بين الاطراف وايضا
تتواصل مع هذه الاشتباكات النداءات
الانسانيه من قبل العديد من الاطرا سواء
كانت الدوليه والمحليه والاقليميه بخفض
التصعيد ووقف هذه الاشتباكات ووقف اطلاق
النار المستمر منذ الامس وحتى اليوم لما
احدث من اسر انسان وتاثيرات سالبه على
حياه المواطنين وحياه السكان خاصه
المقيمين حول
المناطق المنتقمه لهذه المعارك في وسط
الخرطوم يعني هذه المناطق التي بعضها
ماهول بالسكان وبعضها يجاور مؤسسات حيويه
سواء كانت مؤسسات صحيه من مستشفيات ومن
مدارس ومن ايضا محال يعني عديده تاثرت
جراء هذه
الحروب او الحرب المستمره منذ الامس نشاهد
او اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من مواقع مختلفه
حتى الان في في مواقع يمكن ان نش يمكن ان
نسمع ايضا الدوري الانفجارات التي تتوالى
من قبل
القوات المتحاربه في هذه المنطقه منطقه
وسط الخرطوم هذا المشهد برمته يعني ينبئ
بان الوضع ما زال يعني في غايه الخطوره
وان الاوضاع تزداد سوءا وان هناك حاجه الى
وقف هذا القتال وايجاد ربما حل بديل لما
يجري الان في في ما يخص المساله
السياسيه في السودان ومستقبل هذا البلد
الذي يتجه نحو يعني واقع خطير ومظلم اذا
هذه الاشتباكات المستمره وايزاء غياب
الرؤى حول الحلول السلميه حتى الان من قبل
الاطراف المتحاربه هذا
التطور الذي بدا على خلفيه صراع حول او
خلاف حول مساله دمج قوات الدعم والسريع في
السوداني ليصبح الجيش موحد مهني
بعده تتم ان تتم استكمال العمليه السياسيه
وتشكيل الحكومه مدنيه ولكن الان يعني هذه
العمليه السياسيه تواجه واقعا جديدا يتشكل
على الارض وعلى الميدان مع تطور هذه
المواجهات الميدانيه التي لا ندري حتى
الان نهايتها والحسم فيها الى اين يمضي
وما هي الخطوات التي ستكون بعد هذا الواقع
الجديد وبعد هذه الاشتباكات المستمره الان
الحديث كله يتمحور حول وقف هذا الاطلاق
للنار الجاري ومن ثم النظر في مستقبل
البلد بعد المرحله ان تتجاوز هذه المرحله
الحاليه والتي كل طرف الان يقول بان ساعه
النصر او الحشمي قد اقتربت لانهاء هذا هذا
الوضع القائم الجيش يؤكد في اكثر من بيان
وهو يعني يريد
وتصريحته بشكل مستمر ومحدث حول تحركاته
وحول انجازات التي يقدمها على الارض
الواقع في الميادين سواء كان في العاصمه
الخرطوم او في الولايات الاخرى خارج
الخرطوم خاصه الولايات التي تشهد يعني
اشتباكات كانت في سواء كان في غرب السودان
او في في مناطق اخرى هناك مقر او ولايات
قال الجيش بان القوات الدعم السريع سلمت
يعني
اسلحتها وانفسهم الى قوات المسلحه في بعض
الولايات التي لم تشهد اي معالج مثلا في
النيل الابيض في كوسي وفي ايضا القضارف
وفي بعض المواقع الاخرى ولكن عموما يعني
انتشار قوات الدعم السريع كما نعلم في في
مناطق عديده في السودان تنتشر هذه القوات
في في العديد من المواقع التي في في معظم
الولايات 18 في السودان هناك انتشار
وانفتاح لهذه القوات الدعم السريع
وبالتالي يعني
وجود هذا التوتر ربما ينعكس سلبا على هذه
الولايات خاصه في في حال ان الاشتباكات
استمرت وانتقلت الى بعض هذه الولايات